and he thinks his audience are even
[__] dumber. And they are, frankly.
He's right. It's very embarrassing, very
shameful, very easily knocked down. So,
this uh this absolute beast of a fella,
even on Twitter, even on Twitter, even
on Twitter,
>> Wow. This is unbearable, isn't it? This
is like quite unbearable. I don't know I
can do any more of this. Like, he's not
actually confused. I This is the thing,
right? He's not He's not legitimately
confused. Oh, well. Oh, well, if it
wasn't your public tape, well, then that
changed everything. Oh, that changed it.
It wasn't your public tag. Well, then
that changed everything. All right, so I
think this story starts here roughly.
Nick calls Aiden dumb on a stream, guys.
Nick calls Aiden dumb on a stream and it
sends everything into chaos again. Their
whole Discord friendship is blowing up
for a third time, guys. Aiden and Nick
Dioro's Discord friendship has exploded
for a third time. It's truly over, guys.
It's It's over. Earthshattering.
Heartbreaking.
I can't believe it's getting this bad. I
can't believe No more Brother Wars. No
more Brother Wars.
Let's see this. Let's see these
heartbreaking scenes. Dude, blocking
Aiden was such a good [__] decision
in hindsight. He was like the last thing
that like kept me bound to that like
entire community. I didn't like nuke
Aiden because somebody stole his phone
and I held him directly responsible the
entire I nuked him because he invited a
psycho skitso [__] salvo pancakes era
troll not era but like type troll to
hang out with him
which was an extremely stupid decision
and then things went like bad
>> like you cut people off because they
hang out with people who are trolls like
what this doesn't even make any sense
dude it makes no sense.
It's just a like a [__] excuse to try
and avoid people that might upset you.
It's like like it makes no actual sense.
It's just like this like total [__]
excuse
>> in a way that I wouldn't even have
expected. This guy is just a total
liability. He's way too [__]
>> No big revelation came out of that. Um
and it's like total liability.
Completely stupid. Can't uh uh can't
hang out with him. First of all, like I
just know for a fact and I hate to say
this, Nick. Actually, don't hate to say
it at all. I'm sorry, but I I am I'm
more intelligent than you. I would
guarantee guarantee you, bro, if we're
to do a general intelligence task. I'd
be infin infinitely more intelligent
than you. But I'm also impulsive. I'm
stupid 20-year-old. I'm I've made
mistakes. I'll continue to do Okay, but
you know, [__] hanging out with Perry
isn't like a massive [__] mistake.
Like, who cares, man? You went and hung
out with someone in a [__] foreign
country. Who gives a [__] You hung out
with some [__] they behaved like a
[__] they looked at your [__]
computer. Big whoop. End of truly the
end of the [__] world. Nick could
have died, Aiden. Nick could have died.
What were you playing at? Liability.
Nick could have died.
So, I learned from sad mistakes.
Obviously, something like that wouldn't
be repeated, and I'd bet my life on it.
Um, and anyone who was like acting in
good faith would be willing to afford
charitability over that. Nick had a
[__] bad take on the Hassan [__] cuz
he didn't understand like the
geopolitical context of like one of the
Okay. Yeah. So now this is I believe the
rest of the drama is actually about
this. It's actually um
stealth EHD content
because now they're going to be arguing
about how Nick came to the conclusion
that
Hassan's comment about Ela Klein being a
valid military target, how Nick came to
the conclusion that wasn't actually that
bad. And Aiden is going to say, "Well,
Nick, the way you came to that
conclusion was I told you because you
were in my chat saying that it was
really bad and I said, "No, it's not
because of this." And then you went out
on Twitter the next day saying how
everyone clipped out of context. It's
not actually that bad. So, obviously,
you did think it was that bad and then
your opinions changed. And Nick's going
to lie, uh, be a meymouthed [__] loser,
try and avoid that fact. That that's
basically the rest of this. So we got we
got to watch through this. Let's see the
>> most like basic criticisms of Israel
which involves the occupation of the
West Bank which then created this like
complete misinterpretation of what Assan
was trying to say and making it look
like a personal call to violence against
Hila Klein in Los Angeles. I explained
this context to him uh and how he his
interpretation was a misinterpretation
off of his lack of knowledge and
unwillingness to research uh the
geopolitical and historical context of a
drama rooted in geopolitics and history
right and when that occurred Nick
revised his take admitted he was wrong
even credited me I thought that was
great but then I didn't go and say
you're like complete inability and
failure do the most basic research on uh
on a concept like the [__] Israeli
occupation of the West Bank before
commenting on a drama rooted in the
dispute between Israel and Palestine
demonstrates that you were somebody that
talks without thinking, making you a
total liability because it's going to
lead to you like crashing and burning
and it's not going to look good for
anyone associated with you and then me
going and cutting him off. I gave him
charitability. I know that's a mistake,
right? I I get that's a mistake. I don't
think it's a mistake you should be
making when you've been covering that
drama. So, I mean, it's pretty obvious
here that Aiden is saying, "I didn't do
that over this small, you know, issue
that could be a problem publicly." So,
why are you doing that to me over a
small issue that really isn't going to
be that big of a deal publicly, but
could but could blow up a little bit.
You know, that that's what he's said.
Clearly, what he's saying clearly
drawing an analogy, making a point for
as long as he has, but I can understand
it. Right? So, he correct himself. We
move on. Right? Just like how I
apologized in regards to what had
occurred with Perry.
>> Okay, I think this is the next clip.
>> Um, and it's like total liability.
>> Why do you think there needs to be a
revelation for me to consider you a
liability?
>> Nick had a [__] bad take on the
Hassan [__] cuz he didn't understand
like the geopolitical context of like
one of the most like basic criticisms of
Israel which involves the occupation
[clears throat] of the West Bank which
then created this like complete
misinterpretation. I don't even remember
what the argument was
>> of what Assan was trying to say and
making it look like a personal call to
violence against Hila CL.
>> Wait. Oh no. He's so [__] stupid.
Isn't that the one take that I don't
agree with them on? I didn't do that.
>> Okay, so here Oh wow. He's so [__]
stupid when the point is obviously that
you had to be fed that take by Aiden
because you were wrong initially.
>> That did I I feel like I've spent like
seven streams arguing the opposite of
this. So, I retweeted something. I saw
Aiden cover it on stream where he played
more context.
>> You I really
>> And as soon as I
>> as soon as I saw there was more context
to the clip that Dan Saltman posted.
>> Sorry. This is unfathomable
[__] cope. This is unf and I went
over this at the time and you can go see
my coverage from the time. I said at the
time the out of context clip, it's still
pretty easy to tell what's what's
happening. You should be able to
identify. There isn't really any super
material context in this extended clip
that makes it like crazy different. It
does make it clearer, but you can still
tell what's happening in the clip. It's
like total cop pretend this extended
clip is like totally transformed. It
just totally change the meaning. It
doesn't.
So, I think it's pretty [__] obvious
that Han [__] mentioning Hila Klein in
current day while describing a valid
military target is absolutely reckless
and [__] stupid. That being said,
there is additional context here that
needs to be shown to provide what he's
actually
>> there's no dude. There's no
understanding of the West Bank required
>> to Nicholas Dioro
>> to hear, oh, this was clipped
uncharitably. Like literally, as soon as
I saw the full clip, from that point on,
I argued it exactly the same as Aiden
>> or somebody that talks without thinking,
making you a total liability because
it's going to lead to you like crashing
and burning and it's not going to look
good for anyone associated with you.
Wait, how are you comparing this to
inviting a crazy person to your house
>> and then you going and cutting him off?
I gave him credibility. I know that's a
mistake.
>> Why would you cut me off for retweeting
a
>> Okay, one minute. So, you can't figure
out what a hypothetical is, what an
analogy is cuz he's a [__] [__]
Fat [__] idiot, right? Let's see
these original clips.
Where is the original? Oh, here we go.
Here we go. Here we go. Known scum [__]
here. nasty violence that Israeli
settlers or the the Israeli military
experiences in the West Bank is
literally legal. Okay? It is legal
resistance against an occupying military
force. I cannot I cannot repeat this
enough. Just like any kind of violence,
any kind of
>> violence,
>> this is the this is the edited one. Here
we go. matter if they're DFLP, PFLP, or
even former FATA militants. Okay, it is
perfectly legal, perfectly valid, and
perfectly moral. Okay,
100%. This is not like a black and this
is not a gray area. This is black and
white. Okay, it doesn't get more black
and white than this. Israel is in the
wrong. Israel is actually engaging in an
apartheid, which is a crime in and of
itself. Israel is doing a genocide in
Gaza and an apartite in the West Bank.
Two crimes in and of itself. And every
[clears throat]
every type of armed resistance against
both the settlers and also the Israeli
occupying force in the so clear
resistance armed resistance against the
settlers or the Israeli occupying force
in the West Bank. So,
even within this tightly cropped clip,
if you're not a [__] troglodite, if
you're not the dumbest [__] on
earth, if you have anything past like a
high school education and are able to,
you know, remember facts about the world
that you may have heard in the news, if
you're past the age of of 21,
you know, you should be able to identify
from this clip alone exactly what Hassan
means. And if you can't, you're a
[__] idiot. You're a [__] idiot.
And you frankly shouldn't be talking
about any of this drama
to be honest.
Westbank doesn't matter if it's your
favorite podcaster's like uh wife that
participated in these ratings. Doesn't
matter if
>> So that's the part they get upset about.
She says your favorite podcaster's wife
when it's obvious from the words he
spoken in that clip. He says any any
armed resistance against the settlers or
Israeli occupying forces in the West
Bank. In the West Bank. In the West
Bank. Key words, in the West Bank. Not
in LA.
Not in
the H3 studio.
In the West Bank. What's Nick's cope?
All right. So, I think it's pretty
[__] obvious that Hassan [__]
mentioning Hila Klein in current day
while describing a valid military target
is absolutely reckless and [__]
stupid. That being said, there is
additional context here that needs to be
shown to provide what he's actually
trying to say in his argument. Uh, cuz I
noticed the clip starts pretty late and
this is probably why.
>> Current political leadership in Israel
does not want a Palestinian state and
the Israeli parliament just approved a
motion to annex the West Bank. like any
kind of violence that Israeli settlers
or the the Israeli military experiences
in the West Bank is literally legal.
Okay? It is legal resistance against an
occupying military force. I cannot
>> like in this context he is absolutely
talking about people who are currently
occupying the West Bank. people who are
actively invading the West Bank, not
people.
>> But you didn't need that extra bit
because he says that much in the short
clip. We just heard it, right? So this
is the extra context. Nick thinks this
extra context changes everything. It
changed everything. Force I cannot
>> like in this context he is absolutely
>> does not want a Palestinian state and
the Israeli parliament just approved a
motion to annex the West Bank. like any
kind of violence that Israeli settlers
or the the Israeli military experiences
in the West Bank is literally legal.
Okay, it is legal resistance against an
occupying military force. I cannot
>> like in this context he is absolutely
talking about people who are currently
occupying the West Bank.
>> So that's what Nick says there. Okay,
apparently that context changed
everything. So what's this? genocide in
Gaza and an apartite in the West Bank.
Two crimes in and of itself and every
[clears throat] every type of armed
resistance against both the settlers and
also the Israeli occupying force in the
West Bank. Doesn't matter if it's your
favorite podcast. It was literally
almost verbatim. The exact same phrase.
He said almost the exact same phrase
verbatim.
But because Nick has to try and concoct
some reason in his head how oh this was
just clipped out of cont. It's not an
obviously disingenuous thing to get
upset about in the first place. It's not
like you're not like obviously wrong and
displaying a deep profound retardation
if you're upset with this in the first
place. He has to concoct some way around
that. So, it's Oh, no. There's actually
this other part of the clip that's cut
off where he says the exact same thing
verbatim that he says in the clip that's
going around.
[__] idiot. And he thinks his
audience are even [__] dumber. And
they are, frankly. He's right.
People who are actively invading the
West Bank, not people who live in
California.
>> I cannot repeat this enough. Just like
any kind of violence, any kind of
violence that the Israeli occupying
force experiences in the Gaza Strip is
actually once again totally legal and
totally moral resistance by the
Palestinians. Doesn't matter if they're
the Alaka Brigade. Doesn't matter if
they're a part of the Palestinian
Islamic Jihad. Doesn't matter if they're
DFLP, PFLP, or even former FATA
militants. Okay? It is perfectly legal,
perfectly valid, and perfectly moral.
Okay? 100%. This is not like a black and
this is not a gray area. This is black
and white. Okay, it doesn't get more
black and white than this. Israel is in
the wrong. Israel is actually engaging
in an apartheid, which is a crime in and
of itself. Israel is doing a genocide in
Gaza and an aparttheid in the West Bank.
Two crimes in and of itself. and every
[clears throat]
every type of armed resistance against
both the settlers and also the Israeli
occupying force in the West Bank.
Doesn't matter if it's your favorite
podcasters like uh wife that participate
in these raids. The violence that the
Palestinians engage in in an act of
resistance against this illegal
occupying force is literally legal.
Definitionally legal. Okay? It's just
the truth. Straight up. It doesn't
matter that they look to be in garb that
makes you think that you understand why
people are coming. What did you say?
>> I think it's like a stupid idea to
invoke Hila Klein in the middle of this
argument specifically unless you do it
very carefully. Uh, and I understand why
people are coming away from this
thinking that he's talking about Hela
Klein in current day. I don't think that
that was the intent behind the comment
that he made in the clip.
>> Like this is the thing. Nick never says
what he believes. He says what he thinks
he has to say and is so [__]
disgusting how reptilian this fat
[__] idiot is. He's like, um, what's
the Digimon called? What's the Digimon
called? What's the Digimon called?
What's the fat lizard called, guys?
What's the fat lizard Digimon called?
That's Nick. That's Nick. Nick's like
that. The one that Digiv evolves from
from from Geckon.
You know, the fat lizard Digimon. That's
Nick. That's what Nick's like. Shogun
Gekckimon. Thank you. Shogun Gekckimon.
That's it. That's Nick. That's Nick.
He's the big fat lizard.
It is just crazy though. He says what he
thinks he can get away with.
It's absolutely insane cuz there is no
part of this that is ambiguous. You're
just a [__] [__] If you can't
interpret it or you're looking for a
reason to be upset and Nick is not going
to just say that. Nick's not just going
to be real about what's going on here.
He can't even read the quote himself.
Let's be real. He has to have it
forcefed to him.
And he's never just going to say the
actual reality, which is that you're
[__] insane if you take issue with
this. You're like a [__] skitso or
like a zogbot if you take issue with
this. And he's never going to say that
because he knows he has to stay on the
right side of Ethan and the right side
of the Hassan hatewave to keep breaking
their money cuz he's a pathetic lying
coward. Pathetic lying self-interested
coward and fat too. And fat too, which
possibly the worst part of it all. Let's
keep watching.
>> Ye clip,
>> right? I I get that's a mistake. I don't
think it's a mistake you should be
making when you've been covering that
drama for as long as he has, but I can
understand it. Right.
>> What?
>> So, he correct himself. We move on.
Right. Just like how I apologize.
>> I We Hold on. Wait. I'm sorry. What? Now
I need to get I need more information on
this.
>> Let's run this back. Let's start this
clip from the beginning cuz we just went
We just went over and we checked all of
that. We showed that Nick's a complete
[__] liar and that he pretends that
this clip changed anything when it
doesn't.
>> Big revelation came out of that. Um and
it's like total liability. Why do you
think there needs to be a revelation for
me to consider you a liability?
>> Nick had a [__] bad take on the
Hassan [__] because he didn't understand
like the geopolitical context of like
one of the most like basic criticisms of
Israel which involves the occupation of
the West Bank which then created this
like complete misinterpretation.
>> I don't even remember what the argument
was
>> of what Assan was trying to say and
making it look like a personal call to
violence against Hila.
>> Wait. Oh no. He's so [__] stupid.
Isn't that the one take that I don't
agree?
>> Yeah, Nick was literally like spuring
out going like support free the climb is
pivotal right now. It's so scary for
people like he climb right now and he's
like uh guys
I think this clip's out of context. It's
not. It's not out of context. It's just
[__] Agree with them on I didn't do
that. Did I? I feel like I've spent like
seven streams arguing the opposite of
this. So I retweeted something. I saw
Aiden cover it on stream where he played
more context
>> you really and as soon as I
>> so like so like I just said we've just
gone over this context been over it
there is no ch uh materially
uh relevant context to that clip that is
left out all of the materially relevant
context is there it's very clear son
statement very clear in fact it is only
the exact same phrase verbatim that has
been cut off that's what Nick's mad
about is that the first time Hassan said
the phrase it was cut off. But the
second time he said the exact same
phrase, it was in the clip. He thinks
somehow that makes a difference.
>> Why? As soon as I saw there was more
context to the clip that Dan Saltman
posted.
>> All right, so I think it's pretty
[__] obvious that Han [__]
mentioning Hila Klene in current day
while describing a valid military target
is absolutely reckless and [__]
stupid. That being said, there is
additional context here that needs to be
shown to provide what he's actually
>> there's no dude. There's no
understanding of the West Bank required
>> to Nicholas Dioro
>> to hear. Oh, this was clipped
uncharitably. Like literally as soon as
I saw the full clip from that point on,
I argued it exactly the same as Aiden.
>> For somebody that talks without
thinking, making you a total liability
because it's going to lead to you like
crashing and burning and it's not going
to look good for anyone associated with
you. Wait, how are you comparing this to
inviting a crazy person and then me
going and cutting him off? I gave him
credibility. I know that's a mistake.
>> Why would you cut me off for ret now
unable to understand a hypothetical? So,
we're literally we're on the we're on
the 4chan, you know, race and IQ copy
bastard with Nick now. That's amazing.
We're breaking new ground. Thank you,
Nick. Thank you, Nick.
>> Tweeting a yeet clip,
>> right? I I get that's a mistake. I don't
think it's a mistake you should be
making when you've been covering that
drama for as long as he has, but I can
understand it. Right.
>> What? Hey, so he correct himself. We
move on, right? Just like how I
apologize.
>> I Wait, hold on. Wait. I'm sorry. What?
Now I need to get I need more
information on this. This is the first
take that I gave on a video. All right,
guys. This is the clip that turned the
entire community in.
>> So, guys, there's a lot of issue here.
There's a lot of issue here. Now, I
don't know the dates. I don't actually
know the dates. I don't remember them
off top of my head, but this is actually
the day after, and Aiden has proven
this. I believe this is actually the day
after his conversation with Aiden. So
this clip, this Oh, this is my first
take I gave on a video does nothing to
prove Nick's point again.
He's just lying. He's just lying. He's
avoiding the point. He's trying to lie.
He's trying not to lose face in front of
his audience. It's very embarrassing.
Very shameful. Very easily knocked down
into an uproar. And I think a percentage
of it is for valid reasons. This is the
clip that most people reacted to. If
anything, they heard an even shorter
version of this. Where's the dance? So,
immediately I'm priming that it's out of
context. Extremely important. We need
>> because you cuz you've already been told
by Aiden that you were wrong about it,
but like we've already established the
clip is not out of context.
>> Criticize what Hassan [__] actually
says. All right. So, I think it's pretty
[__] obvious that So, I play that.
Yeah, this is like
>> I think this is totally fine.
>> Palestinians doesn't matter if they're
the Ala Brigade. Doesn't matter if
they're part of the Palestinian Islamic
Jihad.
>> Okay. There's the additional context. I
think I [__] up stories worse than
this.
>> Every [clears throat]
armed resistance against
>> I don't even think I did anything wrong
in this.
>> Look, you're taking the time to get the
full context and make a ferris.
>> So, he didn't actually report on it
wrong on his stream. The thing is his
take was wrong initially. He said about
in Aiden's chat and he was tweeting
about it. Then Aiden informed him and
then he flipped. That's what happened.
You didn't report on it on your stream.
No, Nick. That's true. That's true. In
this case, you didn't say something that
was totally incorrect on your stream,
except for claiming the reason this was
bad was because it would cut out of
context when it wasn't
response. I actually saw this on Aiden's
stream. That's why I got it from Aiden
Project stream. Uh, so it wasn't as
nuclear as I feared. It's a double-edged
sword. People spent the last few hours
defending what I saw. Didn't So, I
watched a clip of Aiden where I saw
extra context. I made it very clear the
extra context. So, it changed my mind.
And Aiden has drawn this to the fact
that I am I'm
>> so know if the extra context changes
your mind, you are [__] [__] You
are a [__] [__] because there is no
materially relevant context that is
clipped out in the clip Dan Sultan
posted then actually in that case as
much as it does make it kind of look
worse in the sense that he doesn't say
the thing twice right. It's like a clip
where I say, "Don't kill anyone." That
might not look as good as a clip where I
go, "Don't kill anyone." Anyway, yeah.
Blah blah blah. Don't kill anyone, guys.
Seriously, that that second one probably
sounds even more like I think don't kill
anyone, right? But you could still get
the same meaning from the first clip cuz
I said the same thing twice and you just
cut one of them out. So, Dan didn't
actually really do anything wrong in his
clipping of this at all.
Nick has just kind of come up with a
reason why. Actually, the public
perception's wrong, but but uh yeah,
son's actually not in in the wrong this
time. Here's my here's my convolted
reason for how actually actually this is
totally fine.
Yeah, it's trying to deflect blame. It's
trying to just like skirt around and
like never be wrong. Never be wrong.
Never admit that people are upset over
nothing and so on. just blatant
>> choosing to not understand geopolitical
issues say because I I didn't hear the
context that wasn't in Dan Saltman's
clip. He did say my response to this is
I'm probably just going to ban his
[__] name from my stream chat and
never talk to him again.
Like dude, who is saying Aiden's name in
your stream chat? Who is who is talking
about Aiden in your stream chat? Who is
talking about? No one's talking about
Aiden in your stream chat. He is such a
thin skinned.
It's crazy. It's [__] crazy. Truly,
what a feminine [__] loser. What a
feminine [__] loser. I guess I'll
just b this from my stream chat and
never talk to him again.
[__] queer, dude. Holy [__]
[laughter]
>> Bye.
>> Additional context.
>> That's good. Good luck again. Same thing
though. Wish you the best. Um, just far
away from me.
>> Stay Stay away from me.
Okay. Oh my god.
Okay. Oh, the throwaway was fighting
with Aiden
about flipping stuff out of context.
Apparently, he didn't. Okay.
Let's see a bit of Aiden's response from
last night then as we've gotten through
the main
>> the main part of this, I think. Oh, is I
wonder if Dioro spoke about I wonder if
he could resist.
>> Let's see. Oh, he's just started. He's
actually just started. So, we won't know
yet.
Okay.
Oh, wait. I need uh
Leroyy's tweets actually, don't I?
Someone send me the Leroy tweets,
please? I don't have the Leroy tweets.
Could someone send me
the way I tweets, please. That'd be
amazing. I'm going to sit here and wait
in silence until you do it for me. Yeah,
I'm going to sit here and just totally
silently wait until I get sent the Lero
tweets. I'm actually going to look for
them myself as well, but I would
appreciate if someone sent them to me.
Ah, here we go. Here we go. So, this uh
absolute
beast of a [__] bloke, Leroy,
made a couple tweets here about Aiden,
except apparently they're more about me.
Apparently, they're more about me.
So, when is this 72726
243 26? Okay, so this uh this absolute
beast of a fella, Leroy says, "The last
few moths, the last few moths has been a
witch hunt on Aiden's and Cahmon's side
of commentary to get Nick on something
he's potentially doing something doing
wrong." He is doing stuff wrong. He is
doing stuff wrong. And I've shown it
many times. I've shown one in this
stream. I've just shown one of the times
where he just blatantly [__] lies to
try and save his own skin and protect
his protect his cash flow.
So, I've shown one just just today
alone. I've shown many before. So, you
can say trying I have shown it many
times. I think Nick is willing to
correct when he's wrong and explain why
he is wrong to which he did. No, he
didn't. And he lied. He even lied in his
explanation here and I've shown it.
Endlessly cries about how horrible Nick
is. This is the first time I've spoken
about Nick in probably about a month. by
being inconsistent then does the same
thing he accuses Nick of doing what have
I done sure so example I don't think
Nick should be required to overextend
slash explain himself to levels that
please Aiden of Queenman's political
standards I don't even know what you're
trying to say there you stupid [__]
even given full context you can clearly
tell Aiden is salty because Nick cut him
off due to puff bar game incident that
par that Aiden had sorry Aiden as a
result of what Nick is saying in the
bolex video then takes it to the point
of Nick has gets his geopolitical
context wrong and said he never even
condemned it on stream for getting the
context wrong. No, he's drawing an
analogy about something that would be
stupid to cut someone off over despite
being a liability. You [__] idiot
dude [snorts]
while at the same time throwing in
Nick's face in the blow clip because
Aiden's salty
queen doesn't like the trajectory of
Nick's channel or the topics Nick
covers. Total [__] lie. I go over the
lies Nick Nick tells. The lies Nick
tells like I've shown tonight.
And again, you're welcome to prove me
wrong at any point.
Nick Hubbs will attempt to ridicule him
over very mild political takes while
calling him inconsistent. Very mild
political takes. What you mean? Where
he's like stumbling his way through
trying to figure out what a Zionist
occupied government is. Is that what you
mean?
Even though Queman is also inconsistent
his own takes. then show an example then
like why say this and then not present
example you so I'm saying Nick's a liar
I've shown examples before and there's
an example if you roll back 10 minutes
Leroy something here Leroy Gro [__]
general Grod over here gorilla Grod
general is a grud that's general gorilla
grod over here Leroy something never
gives a [__] example it's just oh
you're being mean to Nick you're being
mean to Nick, you mean you're being too
mean to Nick. You're going too far
against against Nick. Well, you're
inconsistent. How? Give a [__]
example, you stupid [__]
You [__] beast. Give me an example.
Not everyone is required to fall in line
with Queen's political views. No, but
you're required to [__] justify your
own views or follow closely what Queen's
takes are, not literally what anyone's
saying. You [__] Mongolade. Because
he's not standing the commentary. L. Oh,
I do get where this eagle testical loser
gets entitlement from. So, two whole
multiple paragraph tweets about me
covering a situation that I was not
involved in. Clips that I'm not
mentioned in. And it's it's two [__]
essays about me. Get a grip. Get a grip,
you nasty [__] Holy [__]
So, let's see some of Aiden's response
here. Apparently Aiden was like crying.
I did see a little bit of a on the
Hassan [__] because he didn't every clip
that every [__] has taken out of
context, etc., etc. Uh then maybe you do
care. Maybe this might be something
worth addressing.
>> What? I don't know. None of this
matters, but
>> completely stupid. Can't uh uh can't
hang out with him. First of all, like I
just know for a fact and I hate to say
this, Nick. Actually, don't hate to say
it at all. I'm sorry, but I I am I'm
more intelligent than you. He's missed
so much context. There is so much
context cut out of this.
>> Context hat. I require context. Context
hat. I require context. Throw away on
this. There is literally throw on this
is wrong.
>> Up until this point, there is like
infinite amounts of context. This is
right after Nick [__] calls me like
dumb.
>> I would guarantee guar guarantee you.
Are we really going to go for like the
[__] like insults instead of like my
genuinely good arguments about why his
assessment of me is a liability? Are we
really going to just call each other
names against my genuinely good is
unfair? And who is clipping this bro? If
we're to do a general intelligence test,
I'd be infin infinitely more. I sound
like a [__] arrogant [__] This just
for no reason bring up intelligence.
>> He is weepy. He is very weepy.
>> Clip this.
>> He's being very weepy.
>> [__] clip this dude. What is going on?
More intelligent than you. But I'm also
impulsive. some stupid 20-year-old. I
I've made okay mistakes. I'll continue
to do so. I learned from said mistakes.
Obviously, something like that wouldn't
be repeated, and I bet my life on it.
Um, and anyone who was like acting in
good faith would be
>> Is this like a friendship application?
Like, I don't care.
>> I literally said, "I have no interest in
being friends with you again. I don't
care if you [__] reach which you did
reach out to me to seemingly offer a
gesture, offer a hand, right?" Uh, and
then you and then I respond. and you I
guess never replied back and blocked me
or whatever. But it's like I I I I have
no interest in being friends with you
again. I'm not applying for it. I quite
literally state the opposite in this
like [__] 10-minute segment which
you're like like talk about
>> cuz I've not been chilling. Guys, now is
a great time to remind you. Okay guys,
309 people here, 50 likes on stream. So
much 250 people when please move the C
the thumbs up and clicking it or
pressing a thumbs up on the mobile
device that be appreciated. If you want
to take your support one step further
you can donate directly through streams
link in the pin chat message. You can
also buy a membership the channel gift
to membership to the channel a whole
bunch of membership throughout the chat
buy chat which I message or buy a super
sticker which YouTube image or gifting
channel I'll describe it to you. You go
to discord.gg/man.com GG/man twitch.com
screaming or rate.com/queman. Thank you.
Thank you. Thank you. Can you hype
streams? Can you hype the stream, guys?
If you can hype the stream, hype the
stream.
You couldn't even It's a 10 10 minutes
total. You couldn't get the context
within that 10 minutes. Like I literally
said, I have no interest. I have no
interest in being friends with you again
to afford to build a [__] bad take on
the Hassan [__] because he didn't
understand like the geopolitical context
of like one of the most like basic
criticisms of Israel which involves the
West Bank which then created this like
complete misinterpretation.
>> I don't even remember what the argument
was.
>> Guys, uh I'm probably off tomorrow by
the way. I'm probably off tomorrow, but
I think when I get back the next day,
if there's not crazy stuff happening, we
might be doing a
a a food slops
uh food stamps retrospective
to
um cover the recent Dan drama. I don't
know if you guys are aware of that.
There's like some Dan drama right now.
Dan called Food Shops a pedophile and
they're both fighting over it. So, um,
and Food Food Chops has been like
spazzing out
saying like Dan's family deserves to get
doxed and all this [__] and get swing
like say crazy [__] about Dan's family.
So, that sounds kind of entertaining.
I'm not going to lie.
what Hassan was trying to say the
argument was the argument was Hassan was
invoke Hassan there was this big clip I
think where Hassan was saying right um
he was trying to make the argument that
members of the Israeli military
apparatus who are within the West Bank
are still valid military targets because
you they are part of the occupying army
on occupying territory and just because
they're not actively combatants does not
mean they're not a part said military
apparatus and therefore legitimate
targets. And to make this example, he
brings up Elila Klein's role as a
secretary, right, within the IDF who
volunteered to go on raids in the
illegally occupied under international
law, the illegally occupied West Bank.
She was not placed there mandatorily.
She volunteered. Right? So to understand
that Hassan is not actively calling for
Hila Hila to be a legitimate military
target now, but rather at the time when
she was in Ramallah, you would need to
understand the broader context of the
Israeli occupation of the West Bank and
Hila's trip to the West Bank uh when she
volunteered to go on a raid within it.
Right. I brought this up to Nick in
private. No, no, it wasn't in private. I
made this argument on stream to him
while he was in the chat. Okay. While he
was literally in the chat. Um and at no
point did he say, "Oh, I already knew
that. I already knew that." He never
said that. And I'm pretty sure we then
go went and spoke about this privately.
Um and even on [__] Wait, here it is,
dude. Even on Twitter.
Even on Twitter. Where's the
>> his voice, man? Even on Twitter. Even on
Twitter. Even on Twitter. I have it
right here. Dude, I had to save the
tweet from what's her face from Pyite
Swirl because I'm blocked,
dude. Did it just not save? Are you
serious, bro? Are you serious?
[music]
Did I not save? Did I not save the Okay,
we'll keep watching. It looked like a
personal call to violence against Hila
CL. Wait,
wait. Oh, no. Oh, he's so [__]
stupid.
Wait, isn't that the one take that I
don't agree with them on?
>> Yeah, after I convinced you. After I
convinced you,
>> this guy this guy's crashing out.
>> This guy's lazy.
>> Spent like seven streams arguing the
opposite of this.
>> Yes, after I convinced you. And I I even
gave that to you to your credit. I only
am making this argument now because and
I even used this to to appreciate at the
time and use this example of Nick being
willing to admit when he is wrong. I've
invoked this example repeatedly. Hold
on. I'm going back to August now because
I have you public I lit this is all
public. I can literally verify this
right now.
>> I'm pretty sure that's the one that I
didn't agree with.
>> You no longer agree with it. That
doesn't The claim is literally that I
changed your mind. That is the claim. So
of course you don't of course you don't
agree with it because I got you to that
point. I'm not claiming that you still
hold this position. Holy [__] of what
Assan was trying to say.
>> I thought I I thought I opened up on my
stream saying I don't agree with that
>> on your stream. Yeah, your stream was
literally if I could just go back get
back to August, I will literally show
you him crediting me on Twitter for
changing his mind. Hold on. This is
going to take two if I I have a really
useful audience, by the way. Hold on.
Hold on. We're almost there. I can It's
going to take two seconds to refute
this. But now, if this gets clipped, it
would be so much cooler if you could see
the clip of me immediately pulling it up
and not [__] looking for it. Hold on.
We're almost there. It was on August
17th or it was either a It was anywhere
from August 15th to August
18th. It's there. One sec. I'm almost
there. I'm on the 20. This guy [__]
tweets a lot. Holy [__]
dude. It's taking for I have it on like
an auto scroll. It's taking forever just
to get there.
>> Holy [__]
>> Like no char.
The whole point was Hassan was not
[__] calling he
>> when did this comment take place? No, I
explained it to you on stream and you
even and the reason I know this and I'm
not just making this up
>> is because Nick
when you go and issue your take on the
17th of August
valid military of IDF. So when I say in
Los Angeles, I mean he's saying she was
a valid target when she was occupying
Morala and part and a partaking uh in
the military apparatus that is actively
illegally occupying said territory.
Right? So I emphasize actively actively
actively he's emphasizing that here. And
I know that not only did he acknowledge
it in the chat when the stream itself
was happening,
you're taking the time to get the full
context and make a fair response. I
actually saw this on exile day. So he's
admitting it.
HE'S ADMITTING IT. SO WHAT IS THE
CONTENTION? What is the [__] dispute?
This is publicly verifiable.
What are you disputing? Why can't you
just admit to this?
literally crying. He is. He's got He's
He's very upset about this. He's clearly
very upset about this. He valued this
friendship. This is why him and him and
Perry had to have that long beach walk,
you know? They had to have that long
walk on the beach and the sit down heart
to heart. Sit down heart to heart under
the stars on the beach.
My god, dude. This is bad.
This is bad, bro. Interesting.
Interesting. So he thinks I'm Okay, this
is going to be really funny because he
he doesn't understand the medium in
which this was explained to him was
publicly documented and his response and
admission to understanding the context
through said medium is public record. He
at this point thinks I'm referencing a
private conversation, which if he thinks
that's what I'm using as my uh backing
for the claim that I'm making, then he's
going to he doesn't need to uh concede
to it. He doesn't need to admit that it
happened cuz he thinks that it's
hearsay. Surely, right? So, is he now
just going to deny that it ever happened
because he thinks it can only be
verified by word of knowledge and
unwillingness to research uh the
geopolitical from GG's. Aiden, my kids
are crying cuz you're yelling. Good
historical context of a drama. He
thought you were talking about VidCon.
Well, I I know and there's no reason he
should think I'm talking about that
because even though this clip is cut up,
I literally say he's not talking about
Hila Klein and then he paused after Hila
Klein and then when he unpaused it says
in Los Angeles.
So obviously I'm not talking about you
in Los Angeles. I'm talking about the
person whose name I'm talking about the
noun that came before in Los Angeles.
That noun being Hila Klein and not
Nicholas or proper noun being Hila Hila
and not Nicholas Dioro.
Holy [__] dude. You rooted in
geopolitics and history, right? Dude,
they got [__] geopolitics in my
YouTube drama. I don't care. Get out of
here, dude. And when that occurred,
>> can you take your geopolitics and put it
somewhere else? It keeps leaking.
>> Based lack of knowledge.
>> Wow. This is unbearable, isn't it? This
is like quite unbearable. I don't know I
can do any more of this.
[laughter]
Guys, there's got to be a different way
of having some of this uh drama back and
be like, uh, is that is Nick said
anything on his his stream yet about it?
No, it doesn't like it. We didn't get
another response from Nick, I don't
think. Based I'm uninformed,
dude. What the are we really like at
levels of stupidity where it's a flex to
not know about something? Are we serious
right now? Into my drama.
>> Nick revised his take.
>> I revised my position.
>> Admitted he was wrong. Even credited me.
I thought that was great.
>> Oh, wait a minute. I actually Hold on.
Wait, whoa. He might be right. Hold on.
Wait, wait.
I don't think we had this conversation.
I think I just watched an Aiden stream.
>> Yes, which I said,
but I don't think I ever changed I don't
think I revised my public take. I think
I opened off by saying I saw Aiden.
>> No, we you
your public take. That's not what's
being contested right now. It's your
take.
>> No.
>> Yeah, but Nick has to move everything
around. Nick's doing a little pop little
cup and ball game. He's doing a little
cup and ball game. He's doing like the,
you know, putting the ball under the
cups. He's spin them around a bunch.
That's all he does for this entire se. I
did watch like maybe 20 minutes of this
Aiden segment last night and all I could
hear was Nick doing just like literally
doing obuscation. He just sits there and
goes like, I can't remember. Was this
that or was it that? Was this that or
that? And just tries to avoid saying
anything for like five minutes at a
time. It's so [__] annoying. Did he
say? I wonder if this is also
documented. What was his take prior to
August 17th? I have to scroll again. I
hold on. Um Um Dude, if only there was a
way where like when you click on
somebody's tweet, it brings you to their
like tweets at the time. Like it does it
show tweet and timeline? Can I do that?
You would think on such an advanced
[__] site.
Okay. Somebody go to the 17th and see
what his take was before he credited me.
Oh wait, hold on. Wait. Kathy just came
in clutch. So this was after
Oh my god, dude. This is documented,
too. Are we serious, bro?
support, dude. How are we still
contesting this? It's all public.
How are we even contesting this?
>> Support for Ela Klein is pivotal right
now. Classic tweet. Classic tweet.
Classic Nick banger. Support for is
right now.
>> Everyone was make like Ethan, every this
was like a big discourse at this like on
that day that Hassan had called for like
harm against Hila. Everyone was talking
about this. This is obviously what he's
referring to. Okay. And Hila does not
need any support because Hassan is
actively not call Hassan is not actively
calling uh for any harm towards Hila.
He's referencing her to make a broader
point about how non-combatant members of
an occupying military apparatus are
legitimate military targets. Since Hila
is no longer uh in Ramala, no support
would be needed. It is very obvious that
your take at that time was different
prior to watching my stream which then
to your credit you revised and then you
do this weasly little thing where you're
now like oh I don't think my public take
was diff okay what about your private
one we've spoken in private I'm pretty
sure we conversed about this privately
and this tweet indicates that you did
have a different take uh prior to
watching my stream hold on let me see
Klein
Uh, what did I say?
>> Like to give a big shout out to Nicholas
Dioro.
[sighs]
Um,
I did credit Aiden on something. This
should be very,
>> by the way, $5 from Crystal. The clipper
did you so dirty. True. $2 from Patrick.
Do you have clippers that aren't against
you? Everyone is against me. $2 from
GG's. Aiden, my kid's crying. Oh,
>> okay. This is
>> Which it didn't.
>> Going nowhere.
>> Do I Is there a part of this I should
see? Do we think?
>> Oh, you're in a
>> Yes. Oh my god. Yes. Yes. Nicholas. Yes.
Thank acting in good faith and will be
willing to afford charability over that.
Nick had a [__] bad take on the
Hassan [__] because he didn't understand
like the geopolitical context of like
one of the
>> That's just not true.
>> Most like basic criticisms of
>> That is true. That just is true. you did
align. Are you going to deny that you
aligned with like the the notion that
Hassan's clip was like uh was like,
okay, if the if the dominant opinion
right now is that Hassan just called for
violence against Hila Klein and this is
like a big deal. Everyone's talking
about it. Everyone's tweeting about it.
When you go and tweet out when you go
and tweet out support for Hila Klein is
pivotal right now. And I'm pretty sure
you had retweeted something that that
also was like reiterating that position,
right? There's enough here to infer that
your original take did not differ from
the mainstream take, which was a
mainstream take uh built uh upon a
misconception
>> literally misconception and no
additional context that changed
anything. By the way, literally no
additional context that changed anything
to not [__] [__] uh of
>> Hila's participate what she was actually
doing within the IDF and the
geopolitical context. uh that makes the
West Bank exceptional and the voluntary
participation in a raid in the West Bank
exceptional
dude is lying on I I don't know where
the lie is which involves the
>> I honestly I don't know where the lie is
of the West Bank then created this like
complete misinterpretation of what Assan
was trying to say and making it look
like a personal call to violence against
Hila Klein in Los Angeles
>> didn't make a public hook
>> I explained this context to him uh and
how he his interpretation was a
misinterpretation of this lack of
knowledge and unwilling to research uh
the geopolitical and historical context
of a drama rooted in geopolitics and
history. Right. And when that occurred,
Nick,
>> I don't think we ever had a private
interaction where
>> I'm not what, dude. WHAT? WE DID TALK
ABOUT this privately to be clear, but my
take is talking about what I said on
[__] stream, I'm pretty sure. But we
also talk about this privately.
>> He explained this to me, but he maybe
after the fact
>> revised his take, admitted he was wrong.
>> Yes, we did talk about this.
is awesome. But then I didn't go and say
you're like complete inability and
failure. Do the most basic research on
on a concept like the [__] Israeli
occupation of the West.
>> So when he says LA, does he mean when we
were
>> I'm going to lose my [__]
I'm going to actually lose my I'm going
to lo How are we this far into it? And
you still don't understand the
statement. Hassan's not talking about
Hila Klein now in Los Angeles.
I.e. He's referring to when she was in
Ramala participating in a [__] raid
on in illegally occupied territory. A
raid which was not part of her mandatory
military service and something she
volunteered for. Uh which by your own
admission the higher-ups would have been
upset about,
right? How how are we this far into it
and you still don't understand why I'm
referencing Los Angeles? You still think
I'm talking about meeting you at an
event that didn't even [__] happen in
Los Angeles?
How How do you
>> Well, I mean, yeah, cuz he's just faking
it. Like, he's not actually confused. I
This is the thing, right? He's not He's
not legitimately confused about what's
going on here. He knows roughly what's
going on. He's just trying to avoid ever
answering anything or taking a stance or
acknowledging that he changed his mind.
>> Still not get it. I honestly I don't
know. Were we in LA or does he mean
>> $2 from GG's? Congrats on 200 live
viewers, Mr. Projects. Thank It's It's
Mr. Underground now. But thank you so
much, GGGs. And thank you everyone.
Support us as always. We're a quarter of
the way to streamly goal if we hit it.
That would be so [__] base. Great way
to finish off the month. We're getting
we're not at the end of the month yet,
but we're getting there. Um, and you
could also like up bank before
>> LA
on a drama rooted in the dispute between
Israel and Palace. Los Angeles, the city
in California. LA can kill Hila in LA. I
guess
>> yes. Oh my god. Yes. Yes, Nicholas. Yes.
Thank you. We finally figured out why I
said Los Angeles even though I explain
what I'm saying. Wow. Thank you. Thank
you, Nicholas,
that you were somebody that talks
without thinking, making you a total
liability because it's going to lead to
you like crashing and burning and it's
not going to look good for anyone
associated with you.
>> Wait, how are you comparing this to
inviting a crazy person to your house
>> and he's going, "So, once again,
comparisons do not need to be identical.
The comparison was me making a mistake
was seen as a liability, right? uh such
a harsh liability that despite being
very good at maintaining secrecy
regarding
>> Yeah, I wish I just had this Nick Vod
without [__] Aiden's commentary, but
I assume he's [__] privated by now,
right? Kathy has a copy.
Uh
oh, wait. I'm getting a message from
Kathy.
Thank you.
Wow.
Thank you for the membership. Thank you.
Oh, really? I can't open that in new
tab. I have to like save it. We can do
this, I guess. [__] it. Where's the
Aiden segment?
[clears throat]
How does this guy manage to cry about
her son every day? It re It really is
like crazy. How far into this VOD is it?
Does anyone know? Just accidentally open
Doomer as well. [__] sake. 446. Okay.
Yo, thank you for the $10, Lil Jit.
Thank you. Huge appreciated with the
super sticker of the games controller
with the deal with it. Deal with it
glasses falling down. Awesome stuff.
Very cool. Very cool.
Okay, here we are.
>> His phone and I held him directly
responsible the entire
>> Here we go. I nuked him because he
invited a psycho skitso [__] salvo
pancakes era troll, not era, but like
type troll to hang out with him,
which was an extremely stupid decision.
And then things went like bad in a way
that I wouldn't even have expected. This
guy is just a total liability. He's a
way too [__]
>> No big revelation came out of that. Um,
and it's like total liability.
>> Wait, why does there need to be a Hold
on. Why do you think there needs to be a
revelation
for me to consider you a liability?
What? I don't know.
>> Well, because if he wasn't considered a
liability before, something must have
changed. No. Oh, like what?
>> This matters, but
>> completely stupid. Can't uh uh can't
hang out with him. First of all, like I
just know for a fact, and I hate to say
this, Nick. Actually, don't hate to say
it at all. I'm sorry, but I I am I'm
more intelligent than you. I would
guarantee guarantee you, bro, if we're
to do a general intelligence test, I'd
be infin infinitely more intelligent
than you. But I'm also impulsive. I'm
stupid 20-year-old. I' I've made okay
mistakes. I'll continue to do so. I
learned from said mistakes. Obviously,
something like that wouldn't be repeated
and I bet my life on it. Um and anyone
who was like acting in good faith would
be
>> is this like a friendship application?
Like I don't care.
>> Willing to afford charitability over
that. Nick had a [__] bad take on the
Hassan [__] cuz he didn't understand
like the geopolitical context of like
one of the most like basic criticisms of
Israel which involves the occupation of
the West Bank. Hindustan Times dropped
an article on parry
>> misinterpretation.
>> I don't even remember what the argument
was
>> of what Assan was trying to say and
making it look like a personal call to
violence against Hila.
>> Wait.
Oh no. He's so [__] stupid.
Wait, isn't that the one take that I
don't agree with them on?
I didn't do that, did I?
I feel like I've spent like seven
streams arguing the opposite of this.
I'm pretty sure that's the one that I
didn't agree with.
>> So yeah, I mean we've already been over
it all obviously, but he says he didn't
agree with it. He did at first. He was
changed had his mind changed by Aiden.
Came up with a cope reason why he didn't
think that at first. Lied through his
[__] teeth and uh all his [__]
fans bought [__] hook sinker. So just
a total [__] lie there from Nick
again. Sean was trying to say
>> I thought I I thought I opened up on my
stream saying I don't agree with that.
>> Making it look like a personal call to
violence
>> started insulting me on Twitter.
>> Why is it always their Why is everyone
You're actually stupid, Nick. First
example
>> in Los Angeles. I explained this context
to him uh and how he his interpretation
was a misinterpretation off his lack.
>> Wait, he explained this to me in
California. When did this comment take
place? of knowledge and unwillingness to
research uh the geopolitical and
historical context of a drama rooted in
geopolitics and history. Right,
>> dude? They got [__] geopolitics in my
YouTube drama. I don't care. Get out of
here, dude.
>> And when that [laughter] occurred,
>> can you take your geopolitics and put it
somewhere else? It keeps leaking into my
drama.
>> Nick revised his take.
>> I revised my position,
>> admitted he was wrong, even credited me.
I thought that was great.
>> Oh, wait a minute. I actually Hold on.
Wait, whoa. He might be right. One more.
Wait, wait.
I don't think we had this conversation.
I think I just watched an Aiden stream,
but I don't think I ever changed I don't
think I revised my public take. I think
I opened off by saying I saw Aiden.
Oh. Oh. Well, if it wasn't your public
take, well then that changed everything.
Oh, that changed. If it wasn't your
public take, well then that changed
everything. Oh, that changed everything
then, Nick. You're not You're not a
total [__] if you didn't say it
publicly then. That that changed
everything. Except you did you did say
it publicly, didn't you? You post 8:00.
So what really Klein's pivotal right now
like a [__] queer. Hold on. Let me
see.
Kila Klein.
Uh what did I say?
Like to give a big shout out to Nicholas
Dioro.
[sighs]
>> Um
I did credit Aiden on something. This
should be very quickly. This should be
very quick to find.
>> I always do the possible
>> at Aiden Revival. This is why, by the
way, you never you never acknowledge
anyone gets anything right ever because
they will hold it against you forever.
Lesson learned.
[laughter]
>> Look at the way this guy's mind works,
bro. Look at the way this guy's mind
works. This is literally like when
Aerodite said, "You can never admit
being wrong on the internet." Bro,
dude, you have to be such a narcissistic
to think like this. It's crazy. And
listen
for me to to pass the first stone on
that. But this is a whole other level.
This is a whole other level.
Um, can I say something to you, Nick? I
really like you. Why?
I think it was I just watched the
stream. Uh,
>> is this really Li?
>> Let me check my latest.
Um, let's see.
>> Can I say something to you, Nick? I
really like you.
>> What is his account? I'm like confused
here. Is it Aiden Underground?
>> Can I say something to you, Nick?
>> No, it's not Aiden_.
>> What is the current Aiden account?
>> Hey, Nick.
>> Thank you. Did I just get 20 or 10? Oh,
[__] Russ Cheney. Holy [__] dude. I
haven't seen you in a minute. How you
doing?
Exiled. That's fine.
>> Can I say something to you, Nick?
[music] I really like you.
>> Why?
>> Damn. Re taking this guy a minute to
find this tweet, huh?
>> Okay. Well, describe.
>> Oh, you just can't find it.
>> I think it's pretty [__] obvious that
Hassan [__] mentioning Hila. Wait. Oh
my god. Okay.
>> All of this, like, listen, this is going
to sound schizophrenic. I understand.
But this is literally him trying to take
up time to make it seem like he's making
an honest effort to engage with some
critique or some point being made when
he's not. He's just sitting there like
clicking around looking for the [__]
tweet. He's going, "Oh, I don't really
know cuz he knows he looks [__]
[__] here if he actually knows
what's going on."
>> Hold on. So, I retweeted something. I
saw Aiden cover it on stream where he
played more context,
>> Nick. I really
>> And as soon as I
>> as soon as I saw there was more context
to the clip that Dan Saltman posted.
>> I think it's pretty [__] obvious that
Han [__] mentioning Hila Klein in
current day while describing a valid
military target is absolutely reckless
and [__] stupid. That being said,
there is additional context here that
needs to be shown to provide what he's
actually dude. There's no understanding
of the West Bank required
>> to Nicholas Dioro
>> to hear, oh, this was clipped
uncharitably in his argument.
>> Like literally, how could you come to a
conclusion about the statement being
made without knowing details of the West
Bank? How could you even understand if
you don't know roughly what's going on
in the West Bank? How would you even
interpret Hassan's statement? You'd be
like, "What? You can kill? What? What?
What?" like you were when you first saw
it. Like you did when you first saw it.
Thank you for the $5.
>> Perry is pivotal right now. I don't
think Nick was expecting to exercise his
spontaneous lie muscles.
>> Thank you for the $5. Thank you.
>> Uh cuz I noticed the clip starts pretty
late and this is probably why
>> current political.
>> So then somebody goes, where is this? Um
you take the time to get the full
context and make a fair response speaks
volumes of your character. And then I
said, I actually saw this on Aiden's
stream. So, I credited him about it
because I found out that Dan Saltman
clipped it out of context and then I
debated Dan on this, I think.
>> So, he didn't debate Dan on this and
we've been over this. We've actually
been over this. The context that Nick
believes changed this clip does not
change this clip. Hassan says the exact
words Nick believes were cut out that
change the context in the clip. In that
clip, he still says it even in the Dan
version. So this is a total lie.
>> The leadership in Israel does not want a
Palestinian state and the Israeli
parliament just approved a motion to
annex the West Bank. like any kind of
violence that Israeli settlers or
>> like literally as soon as I saw the full
clip from that point on I argued it
exactly the same as Aiden
>> or the the Israeli military experiences
in the West Bank is%
doesn't
matter
>> tense a lot
>> makes you think that they're in the
right
>> it sounds like he's like conflating past
and current tense a lot I think it's
like a stupid idea a to invoke Hila
Klein in the middle of this argument
specifically unless you do it very
carefully. Uh and I understand why
people are coming away from this
thinking that he's talking about wait
also this isn't August
but then I didn't go and say you're like
interpretation off this lack of
knowledge and unwillingness
the
>> geopolitical and historical context of a
drama rooted in geopolitics and history.
Right. And when that occurred, Nick
revised his take.
>> Revised my take?
>> Admitted he was wrong.
>> I think I think Nick's Nick spoke about
a couple things. It was I think the
brothel thing and brothel and diddy
stuff was there, I think, and the doxing
stuff.
I think he argued with him about the
Twitch toos or whatever about whether
the gun thing came under the doxing
rule.
>> Even credited me. I thought that was
great. But then I didn't go and say
you're like complete inability inless. I
explained misinterpret [__] because he
didn't understand like the geopolitical
contacts of like one of the most like
>> I think I was bombed every time I talked
to Aiden at VidCon. I think by the time
I spoke to Aiden on any given day I was
completely bombed
>> basically
>> or stoned
>> criticisms of Israel. Good thing he's
not talking about VidCon, then it
then created this like complete
misinterpretation of what Assan was
trying to say and making it look like a
personal call to violence against Hila
Klein in Los Angeles. I explained this
context to him uh and how he his
interpretation was a misinterpretation
off his lack of knowledge and
unwillingness to research uh the
geopolitical and historical context of a
drama rooted in geop.
>> Is he saying this happened at VidCon? I
need to I'm sorry. This is so clipped to
[__] I don't know if this person is
doing this on purpose.
>> I'll continue to do so. I learned from
said mistakes. Obviously,
I bet my life on it. Um and anyone who
was like acting in good faith would be
willing to afford charity over that.
Nick had a [__] bad take on the [__]
because he didn't understand like the
geopolitical context of like one of the
>> that's just not true
>> most like basic criticisms of Israel
which involves the occupation of the
West Bank which then created this like
complete misinterpretation what was
trying to say and making it look
>> he says as he's actively revising his
take on what his take was in real time
deflect deflect deflect
>> thank you for the $5 thank you
>> personal call to violence
[clears throat] against Hill Klein in
Los Angeles
>> didn't make a public
>> I explained this context to him uh and
how he his interpretation was a
misinterpretation off his lack of
unwillingness
and historical context of a drama rooted
in geopolitics and history. Right?
>> I don't think we ever had a private
interaction where he explained this to
me. But he private interaction like it's
just like it's like truly this is the
the cup and ball game. This is just the
shifting around constantly just making
it so you the audience is just like oh I
don't even really know what he's talking
about at this point. I don't even know
what he's talking about at this point. I
don't even really know. Yeah. It sounds
like Nick Nick. It sounds Nick was
right. Doesn't think Nick was right.
That's that's all he wants to happen.
It's no honest effort to engage what
Aiden's saying here. He He literally
does not give a [__] It's just like to
It's lame. It's so lame. It's like lazy
as [__] It's dishonest.
It's unintelligent.
There is no redeeming aspect to this
behavior.
>> Revised his take, admitted he was wrong,
even credited me. I thought that was
great. But then I didn't go and say,
"You're like complete inability and
failure. do the most basic research on
on a concept like the [__] Israeli
occupation of the West.
>> So when he says LA, does he mean when we
were in LA or does he mean
>> bank before commenting on a drama rooted
in the dispute between Israel and
Palestine?
>> Like they can kill Hila in LA. I guess
>> that you were somebody that talks
without thinking, making you a total
liability because it's going to lead to
you like crashing and burning and it's
not going to look good for anyone
associated with you.
>> Wait, how are you comparing this
supporters can stay on that side? Okay,
stay on that side. I know that's a
mistake. Why would you cut me off for
retweeting a yeet clip?
>> Right. I I get that's a mistake. I don't
think it's a mistake you should be
making when you've been covering that
drama for as long as he has, but I can
understand it. Right.
>> What?
>> So, he corrected himself. We move on.
Right. Just like how I apologize.
>> I Wait, hold on. Wait. I'm sorry. What?
Now I need to get I need more
information on this. Uh, what was my
This is the first take that I gave on a
video where I was actually talking about
it on the platform where I make content.
By the way, this is why you don't tweet
ever anymore. This is just complete
waste of your time. Um,
where is it? It would be
look up Hilo. Hila would be in the
title, right?
Okay.
So, what did I say here? every
[clears throat] every let's see seconds
long.
>> So this is totally irrelevant because
this is like after the date of the
conversation with Aiden. So totally
totally irrelevant point being made
here.
>> Long and he said it was upscaled. Was
that mean it was like AI up? Okay. So I
title it Hassan [__] referred to
Helilocline as a valid target. Let's see
this. Let's see the very first couple of
sentences.
[music]
All right, guys. This is the clip that
turned the entire community into an
uproar. And I think a percentage of it
is for valid reasons. This is the clip
that most people reacted to. If
anything, they heard you.
>> Yeah. This is the day after the day
after the conversation with Aiden.
>> Shorter version of this. Where's the
dance? So immediately I'm priming that
it's out of context. Salman cut. That's
the one that I really want to listen to
because that one is like 30 seconds long
and he said it was upscaled. Does that
mean it was like AI upscale? They went
to like [__] obscene lengths to get
this clip as short as possible. Um, let
me see this. Where's the Dan Saltman
[__] cut? Is this DBL? Oh no, this is
not it either. What is Dan's current
Twitter? DBL sounds like [__]
psychotic. Here's the highquality edit
of Hassan wishing for healless death.
Please do not use the stuff like
>> there's like against truth
>> with this context. If this is the only
thing you hear, there are people who
think that Hassan is not inching towards
not dog whistling. They think that he is
literally saying that you could go and
kill Hila Klein in current day. That's
that's not what the clip is. I I hate to
be the bearer of bad news. That being
said, I think that this is a clip of
Assan [__] being completely [__]
brain broken by the constant feud of
Ethan Klein to the point where he throws
something in that legitimately doesn't
fit with the argument that he's making
in the video. In this clip, and I'll
play it again in Gaza. Okay, so obvious
that Hassan [__] mentioned extremely
important. We need to criticize what
Hassan [__] actually says. All right,
so I think it's pretty [__] obvious
that So I play that. Yeah, this is like
>> I think this is totally fine.
>> Palestinians doesn't matter if they're
the Alexa brigade. Doesn't matter if
they're part of the Palestinian Islamic
jihad. Okay, there's the additional
context.
I think I [__] up stories worse than
this.
>> Every [clears throat] every type of
armed resistance against
>> I don't even think I did anything wrong
in this
reckless to do that. I think that people
can take that the wrong way. My evidence
for that is the fact that
>> Nick has Nick has investigated himself
and found himself innocent. Awesome.
>> Assumed it was about killing Hila Klein
today and a bunch of people on Twitter
are justifying it because of of her ride
along that she did uh like some [__]
20 years ago, right? Like even if the
statement isn't explicitly that [__]
Hila client is
>> okay. Did I mention Aiden here? Maybe I
said something that would give him some
here. Okay. Yeah. Look, you're taking
the time to get the full context to make
a fair response. I actually saw this on
Aiden stream. That's why I got it from
Aiden Project stream. Uh so it wasn't as
nuclear as I feared. It's a double-edged
sword. People have spent the last few
hours defending what has been. So I
watched a clip of Aiden where I saw
extra context. I made it very clear the
extra context is what changed my mind.
And Aiden has drawn this to the fact
that I am I'm choosing to not understand
geopolitical issues because I'm I didn't
hear the context that wasn't in Dan
Saltman's clip. He did say it.
>> So again, the context was in Dan Sman's
clip. Going to keep saying this. Going
to say it every time Nick says it. The
context was in Dan Saltman's clip. The
exact same line that Nick thinks was cut
out was also present in the clip.
Harry, uh, does it change anything that
Hassan confirmed the clip was out of
context, to which I said,
>> "No, I think this is the Yeah, here.
Let's see what he has to say from
Destiny stream."
>> All right.
>> Okay. I don't know.
In regards to
>> I don't know. My response to this is I'm
probably just going to ban his [__]
name from my stream chat and never talk
to him again. [laughter]
>> Bye.
>> Additional contacts.
>> That's good. Good luck. Again, same
thing though. I wish you the best. Um,
just far away from me.
>> I guess we just go to the first one.
Star Smiley. Oh man, sexual assault
right off the bat. Okay, so guys,
trigger warning. Sexual assault. Okay,
this I'm going to share this story. I'm
gonna read as much as I can as possible
so people can know who this shay person
is.
>> I wish somebody would read it and give
something some kind of take.
Um, you know what I'm
>> Okay, well that's that looks like the
end of that segment, I think. Right.